louis à toi tu m'en fais une attention
qui montre qu'un but c'est bientôt la
fin du match s'est fini le match est
terminé
quittée enfant s'arrête parce que sans
ça on va tous est épuisé un ange une
idée on va aller voir julie elle aura
certainement une histoire de fêter ça
nous reposera bien oui sinon je lis à le
match est déjà fermée est terminé mais
on est mort de fatigue et quelques a
gagné personne on a fait match nul mais
ça paraît facile et ben bravo tout le
monde elle d'angély je pensais que tu
pourrais peut-être nous raconter une
histoire pendant qu'on se repose
ah bah justement je viens de lire un
poème de jacques prévert voulait que
vous ayez tchatche verbe évidemment les
eaux s'installe dans l'herbe des enfants
et on écoute julie il s'agit d'un poème
de jacques prévert qui s'appelle pages
d'écriture 2 et 2,4 ktk thuy tu étais
huit fonds 16 répété dix mètres de haie
de 4 4 et 4 8 eut été huit françaises
mais voilà l'oiseau lyre qui passe dans
le ciel
l'enfant le voit l'enfant
l'entente l'enfant l'appel sous moi
jouent avec moi oiseaux alors nous
raison destans échoue avec l'enfant le
et 2,4 répétés d'une m et l'enfant joue
l'oiseau joue avec lui 4 et 4 8 8 et 8
concèze et sai 16 qu'est ce qu'ils font
une foule rien savais faire et surtout
pas 32 de toute façon elles s'en vont
l'enfant a caché l'oiseau dans son
pupitre et tous les enfants en temps de
sa chanson et tous les enfants entend de
la musique et 8 à 8 à leur tour s'en
vont et 4 à 4 et 2 à 2 à leur tour fiche
le camp et à la s'en vont également et
l'oiseau lyre joue et l'enfant chante et
le professeur cris quand vous aurez fini
de faire le pitre
mais tous les autres enfants écoutent la
musique et les murs de la classe
s'écroule tranquillement et les vitres
redeviennent sable lancre redevient au
les pupitres on redevienne arbres la
craie devient folle elle ne porte plus
redevient moisson est là bravo bravo
julie c'est vraiment un très beau poème
et tu l'a très bien dit n'en fait pas
beaucoup du mur qu'est-ce qu'il ya
casimir ce poème ne tenais pas le poème
est très beau c'est vrai mais la façon
de le raconter et parfaitement des
motets de mode mais moi je mens pas une
autre façon de raconter une histoire
si à ans la joie commenté aa prince est
intéressante et du peut nous montrer un
exemple si vous voulez je vais vous
jouez des histoires et et vous devrez
deviner quel est le personnage on
carrefour ida s'est senti heureux c'est
une bonne idée
d'accord mais il faut d'abord que
j'appelle ma malle magique à magic bien
ici encore
hop hop hop par casimir tamales magique
est de plus en plus magique je l'avais
jamais vu faire ça je lui ai apporté
quelques petits perfectionnement
technique
elle marque beaucoup mieux mais elle
parle aussi
oui enfin ça c'est plutôt un
inconvénient
bon alors vous êtes prêt on peut
commencer à lui on est prêt bon vous
avez bien compris les enfants
casimir va nous montrer les personnages
et des histoires différentes et on va
chercher ce que c'est à chaque fois et
vous aussi chez vous à nous chercher et
vous essayez de trouver les premiers
bons alors attention première histoire
bonjour mergault
je vous ai apporté une galère et un
petit pot de beurre
alors les enfants qui est le petit
chaperon rouge s à casimir
wen vous avez trouvé tout de suite je
vais trouver julie kafui je pense que
chez eux les enfants avaient tout de
suite trouvé aussi qui nous fait autre
chose
autre chose alors allez deuxième
histoire moi monsieur
si j'avais un tel mais il faudrait sur
le show que je me lance plus tard ça
c'est un pic
c'est un cap c'est un roc cody jean roch
c'est une péninsule bravo alors vous
pouvez chercher chez vous qui s
et à la raison soro est ce que ces euro
à 12 heures à l'aube des drones au sort
on appartenait à qui un grenat sort je
vais mettre à la raison
voilà pour le marquis un petit chat
cyrano de bergerac
voilà cyrano de bergerac d'edmond
rostand
vous avez trouvé dont casimir qui nous
ont fait un troisième histoire
allez-y ma chère moi j'ai tout mon temps
je ne parte pas bêtement ma maison sur
mon dos alors alors oui et acquis par le
lièvre à bien glisser d'ange à la tortue
relief le lien et la tortue et qui a
écrit cette fable vous ne savez pas ses
mots cieux dans de la fontaine je suis
certain que tous nos amis chez eux
retrouvez bombe à casimir tu nous fais
un autre personnage qui te plaît une
autre histoire
attention bandits ne bougeait pas
sergent garcia où je vous raser la
moustache d'un coup d'épée alors qui est
ce personnage 0 on l'a vu connaissiez
tous vous êtes viré euros mais c'est
casimir je suis euros et 1 qui panier
vous au sergent garcia rend cette
crapule là vous aviez trouvé le cheveu
parfait casimir grâce à sa malle magique
nous fait un autre personnage allait les
énergies et n'oublie pas que tu dois
être rentré avant le douzième coup de
minuit
sinon une carence redeviendra citrouille
et chauveau redeviendront sourire alors
en tout cas casimir quelle élégance et
fille
c'est la vie mais il a fait de
cendrillon et soquem c'est ça oui c'est
la gentille fée c'est la gentille parce
que y'en a une qui est très méchante
de fait dans cendrillon et bien bravo
casimir un autre personnage
attention
casimir mon sort de rappeler qu est-ce
qui part il comme peu plus forte et
quasi mets et des mots et 10 dont
casimir
je croyais que tu as mal magic était
très perfectionné août en panne
mais quand we were points d'al gore on
arrive